Is America headed for a civil war?
According to the followers of one fast growing online subculture,
increasing political polarization and instability will inevitably lead to a domestic armed conflict,
which they refer to as Civil War 2, Electric Boogaloo.
Electric boogaloo! The ultimate show.
That's a play on the title of a 1984 break dancing film from which the movement known as the Boogaloo,
aka Big Igloo, aka Big Luau, also derived its name.
The Hawaiian shirt wearing gun toting activists known as Boog Boys have migrated out of meme space
and into the streets, showing up at Black Lives Matter demonstrations in many American cities
in apparent sympathy with the cause.
The media have called them white nationalists and accelerationist terrorists.
The Boogaloo movement is, for the most part,
a libertarian group, according to one member.
But these labels don't capture what this dispersed
movement is all about.
The Boogaloo movement is Gen Z second amendment
activism.
It's members forego the patriotic symbolism of traditional militia movements
for flowered apparel, bright patches, and colorful memes.
Their approach to organizing resembles Hong Kong's decentralized, privacy-conscious,
and social media heavy protest movement.
They're digitally native activists, raised on Instagram and Tik Tok,
who understand that in the world of online feedback loops,
actions are often less important than the way they're presented.
Their online rhetoric is infused with paranoia. And its members circulate unfounded theories
of rampant pedophilia, which they say must be stamped out extra-judiciously if necessary.
They claim that societal breakdown is inevitable, but their public stance often makes it seem as if
a violent civil war is something they'd like to see happen.
And the movement's organic leader-less structure leaves it highly susceptible to being co-opted
by its worst, most dangerous actors.
The members that Reason spoke with stand against gun control, the drug war, and aggressive policing.
We believe that everyone deserves to be free, quite simply,
and we don't like federal government all that much.
Sometimes they've aligned themselves with
right-wing militia groups, at other moments
with Black Lives Matter.
The one issue that seems to unify them is
a conviction that armed resistance
to government overreach is entirely justified.
They could tear gas us, but they ain't going
to tear gas us.
You can try.
I don't incite violence.
I incite defense.
I would say it's a very powerful movement
that has come together and unifies against
racism, tyranny, pedophilia, government overreach.
It's one of the biggest unified movements there has been among gun owner, freedom loving Americans.
Mike Dunn has become a visible face in a mostly
faceless movement.
On October 8th, police arrested Dunn for allegedly
trespassing while open carrying a firearm
at a rally for libertarian presidential candidate,
Jo Jorgensen.
You're telling me that you enforce the unconstitutional law.
Dunn says he left home at age 16 and joined
the Marine Corps a year later.
When he returned to Virginia, he embarked
on a new political project.
The gun control push was getting really heavy
in Virginia and so I began building militias
and connecting them all together under one head.
Then my buddy, who I was connected with through
some militia work and online was Duncan Lemp.
In March, Montgomery County Police shot to
death 21 year old Duncan Lemp
in his Maryland home after bursting in, in the middle of the night with an arrest warrant.
I believe they blatantly killed him in cold
blood and we were going to have justice.
After he was killed, it really pushed me to
become part of the Boogaloo movement.
Lemp's death gave rise to theories that he was targeted for his involvement with the militia movement.
Police say they were seizing firearms he wasn't
allowed to own because of a juvenile conviction.
The Lemp faction of the Boogaloo movement
often use his name as a social media handle
and regularly post about police brutality.
While online racist groups speak of the Boogaloo as an impending race war,
this group portrays it as a sequel to the American revolution.
Dunn says he was drawn to the movement by
its hard line stance against racism,
which set it apart from other armed movements.
I had grown up country, flying the rebel flag,
saying some pretty dumb stuff and
that's something that attracted me to the Boogaloo movement was how much they hated racism
and how much they weren't willing to deal with it. And so I began changing some of my personal viewpoints
and began understanding things.
Boogaloo members have marched alongside Black
Lives Matter protesters,
although their presence hasn't always been welcomed, and they've clashed with racist groups.
The Boog Boys once led a chant of, "white
supremacy sucks," disrupting a speech
at a pro gun rally in Richmond. White supremacy sucks.
We're not white supremacists, we believe in liberty for all regardless of race, gender, whether you're trans.
It doesn't matter, we need liberty for all.
John, who asked that we identify him only
by his first name, runs a Boogaloo themed
Instagram page called too savage for statists.
In addition to supporting Black Lives Matter, he was in Hong Kong in 2019,
helping pro-democracy demonstrators.
He says there are parallels between the two
protests movements.
How the Chinese media describes the Hong Kong
protestors...
Hong Kong was rocked by another violent clash
on Sunday.
Again, between rowdy youth and police.
The exact same way the conservative media
in the US described the BLM movement.
A small group of highly aggressive, emotionally
charged activists took over our culture.
They forced the entire country to obey their
will.
I don't think conservatives in America would
like to compare themselves to conservatives
in China, but that's really how it is.
I was worried that we would have seen more
violence directly attributed to the movement
than we have seen currently.
Journalist Robert Evans coauthored an investigation
of the movement for the website Bellingcat.
He says the first time he noticed the Boog
Boys appearing at in-person events
was at the January 2020 gun rights rally in front of the Virginia State Capital.
I began sort of after that point getting concerned
about what impact they were going to have
on the protests this summer, because obviously
2020, I've been expecting for a while,
was going to be a pretty harsh summer in terms of protests.
So the fact that there was this group of folks
who were kind of committed to the idea
of a societal breakdown and a civil war,
or at least committed to the idea of getting into gunfights with the police,
which was a big thing that I noticed in a lot of their early sort of memes,
that concerned me, which was why I started following them so closely.
No movement can tightly control its message, especially one as decentralized as the Boog Boys,
meaning anyone can easily carry out
violence and acts of terror under their banner.
One man accused of killing a sheriff's deputy
and federal agent in California had a Boogaloo
patch in his car and allegedly scrawled Boogaloo
phrases in blood on the hood of a vehicle.
The Department of Justice has charged three
men connected to the Boogaloo movement accused
of planning to incite violence with molotov
cocktails at a Las Vegas Black Lives Matter rally.
The FBI has even attempted to link Boogaloo
members with Hamas in order to charge them
under international antiterrorism laws, and
a federal law enforcement officer told NBC news
that some of the men involved in the plot to kidnap Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer
have ties to the movement.
I don't want to downplay the danger of this because you've got thousands of armed people talking about
wanting to contribute to a societal
breakdown.
Dunn and John both deny that they are actively
trying to accelerate domestic warfare,
but rather want to be prepared to resist a tyrannical government power grab.
In reality, nobody wants a war, nobody.
We are prepared, but that's something we don't
want to happen.
At the end of the day, we don't need accelerationists.
This is going to happen whether people want
to do or not, sadly.
Mad Dog Mattis said something, "If you want to screw with me, please don't,
but if you do skrew with me, I will kill you all."
And I think that's the mentality of the movement.
But Evans thinks the fixation on collapse and violent conflict can become a self-fulfilling prophecy
as the presence of more armed civilians on the streets increases the likelihood of an inciting incident.
As someone who's reported from civil wars,
if they had a real physical understanding
of what civil war means and what it would
mean in this country, they wouldn't be buying
AR-15s and ammunition, they would be dedicating
their lives to stopping that from happening
every single way that they could, because
there's nothing I can imagine that's more terrifying.
Our founders put the second amendment in place.
The "armed people" was meant to be a check.
They wanted the people to be able to outgun
the state if they overstepped their bounds.
The Boog Boys are only one of several armed
groups showing up at protests.
There are also the pro-Trump Proud Boys, which
drew media scrutiny after Trump's ambiguous
statement about them in the presidential debates.
Proud Boys, stand back and stand by.
And there are black nationalist gun groups
like the Not F*cking Around Coalition,
and various militia groups like the Oath Keepers
and Three Percenters.
In the event of the predicted conflict between
warring political factions actually happening,
it's not entirely clear what side Boog Boys
like John and Dunn would align with.
Neither support Donald Trump or Joe Biden,
instead preferring libertarian Jo Jorgensen.
And in the field Boog Boys have often walked
a fine line, attempting to position themselves
as an armed buffer between police and demonstrators, peacekeepers between leftist and rightist groups,
as well as protectors of private property.
That citizen was wrong and I'm all for protest,
but you can't be destroying your neighbor's houses and businesses.
It's probably the largest actively armed movement
in the United States to date.
I know at one time we could have created a
Facebook group and had 100,000 people in it
that were dedicated.
We have groups everywhere, every state there's
Boogaloo Boys, so it is massive.
It is certainly the largest movement I have
seen in my lifetime in the United States
that is focused around armed citizens taking political action that focuses around those arms.
To understand the group's potential reach,
Evans says it's important to recognize
that apocalyptic narratives are deeply ingrained in the American psyche,
and that as principled as some of its members may sound, that the meme at the center of the movement
is still one of impending war.
How many Boogaloo folks are there? I don't know.
How many folks do I think are out there who
are interested in these ideas,
and who are following these communities to some extent and who find this kind of conversation
about what they will do in a civil war, and their excitement for said conflict?
I wouldn't be surprised if it was a couple
of million in this country.
I think one of the things that isn't done
enough, that you ought to do with talking about this,
is there's a direct line between the zombie apocalypse memes and stuff that were such a rage
in the early aughts, and the Boogaloo.
That's where a lot of the people who are into this started buying guns, started buying arms,
started buying survival equipment.
More than anything what the Boogaloo has done
is taken that impulse and attached to it something
much more realistic because we're not going
to deal with zombies ever.
We might have a civil war.